[Music]
and chicken fashion news Oh smoothly by
chicken feet chicken feet
a woman describes the booming business
of luxury chicken diapers what what the
hell is this is it that bridge made out
of chicken or chicken wearing diapers
chicken feathers what do you guys think
chickens wearing diapers cuz [ __ ]
Birds [ __ ] everywhere people watch
chicken pets because there's fancy
chickens chicken diapers are so cute
they look kind of cute
that's nasty TIFF loves just little
things even though it's a diaper I don't
care it's so cute I don't want diapers
on my chickens is that why you like
Asian guys cuz they have little ice I
said little dicks no it's not a joke no
cuz everyone said hey you like Asian
stuff agent stuff agent guys eugen
gaijin guy what do you say agent case
not really I just got stuck with one
that was a true shoe what a bear what a
[ __ ] yeah if it was like holy like
that like an extended to every single
aspect of my life I would live in one of
those tiny little home that Steve thinks
religious I think everyone who's smaller
than me is a minute yeah
am i a [ __ ] I'm only smaller but like
honestly yes because I've people aren't
shorter than me I just look at them as
short we can make eye contact like here
to here still I mean I can definitely
see over you but just because someone's
a little [ __ ] doesn't mean that their
dick is little either oh yeah yeah they
have a small case he's [ __ ] home good
guess he's not a [ __ ] heavens no no no
it was more surprising at the point he
thought you know how I know crazy huh
you know I know cuz I watched you saw
more basketball so when we were at the
pool when we were at the retreat Casey
did a belly flop and I heard two
splashes but it wasn't a little splash
and the first flash sounded bigger than
the second one T which is kind of crazy
I think about that you know I was
impressed we're just gonna keep doing
these you know how I do it let me think
of one I'll tell the middle article
about it no quite as listening you know
why I know Casey's hung is because
whenever he walks up to the wall his
nose never touches the wall you know I
know Kesey's huh cuz every time we go to
a restaurant Casey's like Casey orders a
lot of food and I'm like whoa what's the
deal with this and he's like I'm
ordering for - you know I know Casey's
hung because I saw it oh you know I know
Casey's huh Oh
COO Steve always has a back prop
you know I know Casey's hung cuz dip
dreads having sex with him she never
likes sucking his dick
they're not know that we've establish
how hungry yes I think we've established
in joyed all of them in the most
inappropriate time okay right when tips
about the show on video by the middle of
video say that Jeff I need it but guess
what I'm gonna walk right out so this
story we're talking about chicken
diapers I knew that so about ten years
ago this woman she who raises chickens
with her daughter in a small farm in New
Hampshire she saw this YouTube video of
a chicken wearing what look like an
upside-down apron that stretched across
its backside and that's when she thought
oh my gosh this is such a good idea to
have a chicken diaper because we would
like to have our chickens indoors but
they just poop all over the place I
think it's a problem why would you watch
a chicken there's so many chicken jets
you're so [ __ ] Phil see there's so
many what pet there's a lot of people
who have chicken pet to lose a pet they
just eat the chicken hmm there's a lot
of fancy chicken breeds yeah I met some
guys that they own three CH three or
four chickens they live in San Francisco
and it's funny cuz it's a gay couple and
they mentioned gay couples in San
Francisco having super fancy chickens
I'm like I miss something I don't know
it was a gay thing to do no no they
didn't mentioned the gay thing
or did I say they did they didn't
mention my friend's brother an article I
saw a documentary where it's just a
bunch of people battling out priced
chickens
wait not roosters chickens like they're
graded based on like their beak they're
the feather patterns like machine like a
dog show oh it's not cockfighting I
thought they were fighting pageant but
fancy chickens fighting is like a
chicken pageant have you seen the
different breeds of chickens oh yeah
they all look crazy today they'll have
some that like feathers cover their feet
and they're like super fluffy or like
really big oh no they have a really big
ones they're small you never saw the
[ __ ] I don't know if it was a rooster
or chicken but there it's in the the
henhouse and then you see the head pop
out all right and then it comes on it
looks like it's a [ __ ] ostrich but
it's not all the monster chickens like
the size of a [ __ ] English Bulldog is
it Casey huge yeah nothing's ever Casey
huge only Casey's cases even chickens
like if you want to raise chickens for
like four four four like how you want to
cook them some people just have them for
engine yeah because they love them have
you ever had chicken mouth before
chicken no what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
give me a Casey's dick joke will you
instead of try and trick me I gave you
like three of them pretty hard you do
give yeah miss Covey I'm just you know
you're laughing in this area to the
party at all I couldn't I couldn't I
need some inspiration I need a supposed
pants down what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you why why do you want to hold this
dick and now you want to get Casey's do
what Casey's dick looks like you've seen
it plenty of plenty of times we [ __ ]
win uh didn't you buy it together
you went what the [ __ ] together Korean
spa gyms you buy gym debugging that I
added the ing bucket spa know why I
don't like to be pampered it's really uh
nothing to do the nudity no one's
pampering you would you go to a spa you
are no no not that agent what it's not a
different temperature like the hot tubs
and stuff or the floors he needs oh I
would do that sure but you have to be
like getting massage them [ __ ] no no
he's an extra charge for everybody men
know that you go to this thing with Bart
he's probably trying to grab your dick
oh that's true I wouldn't go as far only
if its erect
if you're flaccid you said you're a
grower not a shower that's what I think
you said so I want to feel a hard erect
big dick but if I don't want to feel a
soft one thanks for clarifying hard
watch out you know you know Casey has a
big dick do you know yet
what do you mean Oh like a joke yeah but
they're not jokes to you they're for
real they're legends Sheeran Casey
stories they're legends as legends all
right anyway chicken diapers so this
this mom and her daughter they started
creating chicken diapers and now at this
point they sell fifty-five hundred to
one thousand diapers which each retail
for eighteen dollars are you okay oh I
had a Casey joke but it's so
inappropriate but keep going no you have
to save the article
come on how much more chicken modeling
can we hear Bob and this is just there's
no purpose they like the golden
retriever of chickens yeah I feel like
chickens like feel prettier you know I
mean like they're just like their neck
gets a little bit straighter and they're
just like [ __ ] yeah and they pop their
little tail ass out a little bit more
you know it's weird there's two things
when I see a chicken is I either want to
hug it or kick it what why do you want
to kick a chicken roaster you want a
kick I get it because they're little
pests like they seem like little pests
yeah the way they move oh yeah they're
dumb as [ __ ] me out though their beaks
are really all I know the guys I was
telling you about they told me that they
had this one chicken that their beak the
beak was like this crooked like a bee
problems you get big braces you get that
[ __ ] fixed oh I want to eat a chicken so
bad I missed chick-fil-a what I love
grilled chicken fried chicken chicken
soup oh no put the Forrest Gump
conversation chicken and dumplings
chicken chicken noodle soup we could win
she can reach a buffalo chicken alfredo
with cheek
my protein mine too I could live without
chicken easy what's your favorite
protein it's fish it's all seafood Marcy
I mean chicken still could geez ever do
that [ __ ] Elementary joke do you like
seafood like Turing was that what was
that from it was a movie that movie that
did that I learned it from my classmates
it wasn't a movie I was in a movie
trailer that kept playing and that's why
kids you thought that kid was original I
did thank you just copy movies all day
it could have been from The Simpsons or
it could have been like a generational
thing that just kept passing you know I
don't think the Simpsons because I was
in elementary school dude I don't know
if this instance or Rock yes it was
since has been around since when yeah
it's been around since we were born
since the 80s
I thought it was early 90s I thought it
was like 90 to 90 no si eighties you're
[ __ ] 26 years 90 90 90 90 90 yeah I
thought it came on in the nineties
whatever December 89 so pretty much the
nineties it was the time you had an
average dick at the point that 1kc had
like you know like I'm [ __ ] an arm
sized a his dick was being born before
him they thought that twins the whole
time
you know how Casey's hung I saw him buy
you know how we know kisses Holly big
nose you know how we know kisses a
big-ass dick okay I saw my Magnum
condoms Geo you put the team on your
back on that we're proud of that I'm
proud of that well I got you babe I
think you think you think if you want to
get this one you should be like you want
to know why Casey's hung and then just
start crying you know you don't you dude
you know how Casey's hung I haven't
walked for days
[Music]
you